Speaker 1: Let's go next to Stony from
Indiana. Stony from Indiana. Welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing.
Speaker 2: Well.
Good. Yes. I was just wondering, I know that you
kind of side on the side of capitalism and some
of the viewers are more on the left side. But I
wanted to see your take on crypto specifically
and kind of there's been some legislation from
Elizabeth Warren and things of that nature. I
just wanted to see if you're a crypto bro or kind
of where you stand on that whole side of things.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so I've got a couple dozen videos
about crypto. I bought Bitcoin and Ethereum back
in, I believe it was 2016 and I've been clear that
I have no emotional attachment to crypto. I don't
think crypto is going to save the world. I also
don't think crypto is uniquely evil. I basically
took the approach back in 2016. This might be a
thing I want to put about 3% of my assets into it.
Crypto. Bitcoin and Ethereum did really, really
well so that 3% would become 6% and then I would
sell half and then it would become 6%
again and I'd sell half. And obviously,
more recently, crypto has diminished in value
and I have absolutely no prediction about where
it's going. Bitcoin could be in five years at
$1,000,000 or it could be at zero. I have no idea.
I think it's very volatile. I think it's risky
and I think many of the use cases that are cited
aren't really that interesting or compelling.
Speaker 2: So I guess more so, to my point is
behind the I've never been much of a crypto
person. I worked in finance on Wall Street
and that sort of thing. So I we kind of stayed
away from it because it seemed like, you know,
a fairy tale. But the more I look into
it, the technology seems very fascinating.
The blockchain sort of technology seems
fascinating in of itself. Even you look at
the things like Jordan, Santa is getting in
trouble for the election or campaign funds,
that sort of stuff. If it was available on the
blockchain, that sort of transparency I think
would help with politicians and knowing what
they're doing with their funds and just making
everything publicly available through that record.
So I don't know if you have anything else to add
on that, but that was just kind of my to say no.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, you're not wrong. I
just don't know that it's that obvious that the
blockchain is the only solution to like having
not not fallen for the lies of George Sanders. I
just I'm I'm not as technologically savvy as one
would need to be for me to definitively
say the blockchain is the solution to
George Santos's lies. Or there's five other
solutions that are just as good. I don't know.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I don't think we prevent like
two or three times because clearly there's not
proper vetting going on from the the sort
of committees. But more so my point is,
if if all of these transactions from every
politician was available on the blockchain,
such as how crypto is designed, the same thing
with the fraud. If there's fraud in crypto,
you can trace it all the way back to its origins.
Yeah, because of the transparency. So more so just
like from a corrupt politician perspective,
even in Indiana or secretary of State bought
a bunch of stuff was kind of put his feet to the
fire about it and we still elected them because
it's a Republican state, we don't really care. So
it's just those sort of things that I mean, from a
transparency perspective, we have zero trust in
our government when it comes to whether they're
using the funds for. I think from a technological
perspective, it's very interesting. And, you know,
just more ways for us to trust the government in
of itself. I mean, this thing could be applicable
all the way to the police forces being forced to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, You know, Estonia, I think I get
it. I just I don't know that blockchain is what
we need for police accountability, vote counting,
determining. I think we're starting to go into
like it seems like it can't it doesn't make sense
to me that it's the solution to everything.
And that's where it starts to get a little
bit weird for me. But listen, I appreciate the
call and we're going to continue to follow it.
Speaker 2: All right. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Stony from Indiana. We're
going to take the quickest of breaks and then
we'll be right back and hear from more of you.